well he is now a resident of Las Vegas
maybe been a topic of one of your
conversations we're talking about Mark
Wahlberg and Wahlberg is also a fitness
fanatic 8 news now reporter Brian will
joined him today for National exercise
day and shows you how to work out like a
movie star
it's National exercise day and we're
going to go to work out with Mark
Wahlberg here at f-45 in Summerlin
Two Gentlemen are going to be coaching
you and guiding you through the workout
today thanks
Ryan Mueller
Mueller's facility in Summerlin where a
familiar face and chief brand officer of
f-45 Mark Wahlberg is known to frequent
Wahlberg believes Fitness is for
everybody and this is his way to do it
I'm always training for whatever role
I'm I'm preparing for at the time but in
a perfect world I just stick to
functional movement changing that range
of motion it
[Applause]
this intense 45 minute workout is meant
to burn fat build muscle and get you
energized for the rest of the day
fitness has been a lifelong journey for
Wahlberg one that you learned by
practice you want to be able to maintain
as much muscle mass and bone density
right lung capacity you want to live a
long healthy life those are the things
you need to focus on lifting too heavy
not recovering enough I mean those are
the things getting smarter as I get
older it's advice Wahlberg believes in
passing along you learn as you go and
hopefully you pass and share that wisdom
onto somebody else as for how the
workout went I mean it looks good you
know you got the swag you just got the
wrong gear on you ought to help me we'll
fix that oh yeah we'll fix that in a
second great job you did good you're
ripping the pull-ups thank you for
coming bro that's what we if you don't
get sweaty in here we're not doing our
job yeah appreciate it appreciate it
yeah thanks for coming in I appreciate
it
I do want to point out Brian will is
passed out in The Newsroom covered in
ice right now we'll check on him shortly
the CDC recommends the average American
adult needs 150 minutes of exercise I
think Wahlberg gets about three times
that and two days of muscle training
every week to stay healthy I'm gonna go
check on Brian okay